hello youtubers it's been up yet from
davos i'm the director of the few Nate's
the the UN program on fighting AIDS in
the world aids has become one of the
make-or-break issues of our time and
without defeating gates there's no way
that for example Africa will be able to
reach development and with 6,000 people
dying every single day it's a major
crisis but the good news is now that
we've got results and that many
countries infections are going down and
two and a half million people are on
treatment compared to basically none six
years ago so the big challenge now is
going to be to make sure that we prevent
HIV that nobody becomes infected but do
we have an hiv-free generation and that
depends on all of us use a condom every
time you know you're not certain that
you know you're having sex with someone
it's not infected and also reduce number
of partners and postpone your first
sexual intercourse when you're very
young so we can do it and we can all
work too it's our free leads